Donald Trump also now hitting back at
Ron DeSantis and going with an attempted
homophobic smear suggesting that Ron
DeSantis may be gay yes it is March of
2023 and this is where we are Donald
Trump apparently out of ideas going with
it's possible that DeSantis might be
into men rather than into women I I
don't I know it's crazy I know it's
crazy
um Donald Trump posting to truth social
in response to desantis's recent
statements about the Trump looming
indictment which we just looked at quote
Rhonda sanctimonious will probably find
out about false accusations and fake
stories sometime in the future as he
gets older wiser and better known when
he's unfairly and illegally attacked by
a woman even classmates that are
underage or possibly a man I'm sure he
will want to fight these Misfits just
like I do and again this is only a smear
to homophobic people right if I found
out a candidate I liked or was thinking
about supporting Were Gay I would say oh
I don't care about that what are their
policies but to a group of people that
would immediately not consider voting
for a candidate that was gay or might be
gay suggesting that there may be Men Who
come out of the woodwork is a smear now
when you look at the exact language of
it it sort of seems like Trump would be
saying well these would be false
allegations against DeSantis but still
it's that idea that with DeSantis it
might be Men Who come out of the
woodwork and then following up on this
attack with another attract attack on
Truth social
quote Ron de sanctimonious is dropping
in the polls so fast that he soon may be
falling behind young Vivek ramaswamy
people are beginning to find out that
Ron wanted to destroy Social Security
and raise its minimum age to at least
70. he also had strong plans for cutting
Medicare and still does nothing good
happens when you are a disciple of super
Rhino Paul Ryan also Florida did great
long before desanctus came along got my
coveted capital E endorsement shot up
like a rocket and won and of course I
won't look at the polls a second time
with you because we just looked at them
in a recent segment but it is not true
that DeSantis is falling in the polls
DeSantis is doing roughly just as well
as he has been doing he does better
against Trump in head-to-head matchups
DeSantis doing worse against Trump when
you include Nikki Haley and a whole
bunch of other people that might run for
that Republican nomination so this is a
full-blown Civil War right now Trump
with a looming arrest going after
DeSantis DeSantis going after Trump and
later what you will see is Don Jr's
involvement in this but that is going to
be much later today we're going to take
a short break and next I want to look at
this is really something else our
friends from the good Liars Jason and
davram
they went to the Lower Manhattan quote
protest yesterday against Trump's arrest
they were interviewed by right side
broadcasting network and it is the stuff
of Legends so we're going to look at
that after a quick break
did you know that every year 30 million
trees are cut down to meet the demand of
toilet paper in the United States alone
here's something really simple you can
do to fight climate change a little bit
in your home our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 from bamboo
stocks which keep growing forever no
trees are cut down it's shipped right to
your door in plastic free packaging it's
fluffy it's soft like regular toilet
paper you're not making any quality
sacrifice and for every box you buy real
paper donates to reforestation efforts
Across America through their partnership
with one tree planted so instead of the
toilet paper you're currently buying
which cuts down trees and wastes plastic
use real paper actively helping the
planet you can set up a recurring
subscription so you're always stocked or
do a one-time purchase the average
American uses 50 pounds of toilet paper
or more every year make the easy switch
switch to real paper you'll get thirty
percent off your first order plus free
shipping go to realpaper.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below